una cuarta parte de la población
africana se enfrenta a la inseguridad
alimentaria según la cruz roja 346
millones de personas en el continente no
tienen disponibilidad suficiente ni
estable de alimentos
la situación se agravó debido a factores
como la sequía el aumento de los precios
de los alimentos y los combustibles el
cambio climático y también los
conflictos se acabarán food security
cada es eso la actual crisis de
seguridad alimentaria es claramente el
resultado de los efectos combinados del
conflicto piense en el sahel en
particular en etiopía que se ha visto
afectada por un conflicto grave en los
últimos dos años pero también es el
efecto de repetidos choques climáticos
sector
jets
primer choque la profundización de las
causas está generando la peor emergencia
desde 2017 cuando 286 millones de
personas sufrían de inseguridad
alimentaria hoy se han sumado 60
millones en situación vulnerable
el panorama es alarmante en países como
somalia territorio afectado en un 90%
por la sequía y 1,4 millones de niños
menores de 5 años estarán gravemente
desnutridos si no vuelven las lluvias en
lo que queda del año
en paralelo la guerra en ucrania amenaza
con acentuar el hambre
más allá de las fronteras esto ha
llevado a un aumento de los precios de
los alimentos y fertilizantes porque
rusia y ucrania son pilares de estos
mercados ha perturbado las cadenas de
suministro y ha aumentado el precio del
transporte generando aún más presión
sobre el mundo en desarrollo muchos
países en desarrollo ya están a punto
del colapso sin cantera redondos versión
de collapse el conflicto ha disparado un
70 por ciento los precios del trigo en
abril frente hace un año siendo tanto
rusia como ucrania dos de los cinco
productores más importantes a nivel
mundial